[Musique]
télécharger un film art haute définition
s'apprend générale +2 minutes ça c'est
si vous utilisez les réseaux mobiles 4g
qui est le plus répandu présentement
pays mais si vous aviez accès à la 5g
télécharger le même film vous aurez pris
moins d'une seconde
la scène gc la cinquième génération de
réseaux mobiles
avant ça il ya eu la première génération
qui a permis l'arrivée des premiers
téléphones cellulaires la deuxième
génération marquée par l'utilisation des
messages textes la troisième à laquelle
on doit la naissance du téléphone
intelligent est la quatrième génération
qui nous a permis de regarder nos séries
télé sur notre téléphone mais la
cinquième génération
ce sera celle de l'internet des objets
parce que la vitesse du réseau va servir
à des technologies comme les voitures
autonomes par exemple qui ont besoin
d'un délai de réponse qui est presque
nul 4 j aujourd'hui le temps de réponse
est encore au tout car en 2050
5 j'ai pour l'instant il ya une débat au
dessus bon il ya des gens qui dit qu'on
aura en bad à 1000 secondes quelqu'un
qui parle 4050 autrement dit dix fois
plus plus plus rapide plus humaine mais
nos machines diverses à la machine pour
détecter même en bas de la scène
j'essaie donc de l' enthousiasme mais
aussi de l'inquiétude
il ya d'ailleurs plus de 170
scientifiques provenant de 37 pays qui
avait demandé en 2007 un moratoire sur
le développement du réseau 5 g il
craignait les effets potentiels sur la
santé humaine
parmi eux le professeur à l'université
mcgill paléo le plan de l'industrie
c'est d'augmenter la dépendance des
individus vis-à-vis du sans fil
donc ils veulent que tout le monde dans
un autobus téléchargent des films en
trois dimensions en deux minutes mais en
réalité on devrait chercher à minimiser
les radiations qu'il produit l'industrie
est totalement ignorante de cette
situation de des experts pensent qu'elle
grand public si au canada va devoir
attendre jusqu'en 2025 pour avoir accès
à la 5 juin mais deux grandes puissances
les états unis la chine se battent déjà
pour dominer le marché mondial
on parle de d'énormes investissements
d'infrastructure de très gros contre un
et c'est sûr que pour les entreprises
aussi bien américaine que chinoise il ya
la volonté de se placer favorablement
sur ce terrain là parce que c'est que
c'est quelque chose qui va produire des
fruits sur des années et des années à
venir 2 milliard de milliard de dollars
les etats-unis comme d'autres pays
craignent aussi que le réseau 5 g qui
serait développé par une entreprise
chinoise comme moi oui soit utilisée
comme - l'espionnage par le gouvernement
chinois
une maison ben si tu veux inviter des
cambrioleurs ont montré des moyens très
simples mais des portes d'une des
serrures tu as des as la main le
problème il survient à partir du moment
où le cambrioleur potentiel c'est à la
fois l'architecte de ta maison
le constructeur de ta maison est à venir
le concierge de ta maison
donc c'est ça un peu les craintes mais
l'as far west et seulement un nouveau
chapitre dans une guerre technologique
entre les etats-unis et la chine qui
dure depuis plus de dix ans et qui
pourrait durer encore